Hola Bienvenidos a reporteros el
documental soy Santiago López González
una joven pareja migrante el sueño por
un futuro prometedor juntos y un amor
inquebrantable estas parecen las líneas
generales de una típica historia de amor
pero a esto sumémosle el imponente
desierto del Sahara como telón de fondo
el hambre la sed traficantes de personas
maltratos corrupción e inestabilidad
política ingredientes perfectos para
crear un escenario infernal para un
migrante Pero cómo contar esta historia
de una manera diferente sin revictimizar
sin dejar en evidencia sus protagonistas
pero también poniendo sobre la mesa esa
problemática de la migración irregular
el tráfico de personas y los profundos
problemas sociales que tienen algunas
naciones africanas es por eso que este
documental que van a ver en unos minutos
y cuyo tema central vamos a analizar y a
debatir un poco más adelante no tiene
imágenes de vídeo en este caso fue
utilizada una técnica de animación
llamada news sketching que nos permitió
llevarles a ustedes con todo el lujo de
de esta historia de Esperanza denuncia y
lucha hoy en reporteros del documental y
debate una historia de amor en el
infierno Bienvenidos
[Música]
tengo 25 años y desde que nací solo he
conocido la guerra en somalia
los islamistas matan a todo el que no
piense como ellos
[Música]
Vengo del pueblo de galgala a los 4 años
mi padre me llevó a casa de mi tío en
argaixa lo hizo por mi seguridad y mi
educación mi madre se quedó con mis
hermanos y hermanas en el pueblo Después
fui asadeva en Etiopía para continuar
mis estudios superiores en ese momento
empezaron a llegar las malas noticias
mataron a mi padre y a dos de mis
hermanos el tercero desapareció
decidí volver a argaixa quería vender
nuestras tierras y salvar a los otros
miembros de mi familia mi tío me hizo
una advertencia
te van a matar así como mataron a tus
familiares Quiénes son ellos el
movimiento de los
sabemos que quieres volver al pueblo vas
a morir apóstata
te encontraremos donde sea que estés
vete hijo ve lo más lejos que puedas
aún así volvía argaiza mi madre estaba
al tanto de las amenazas
[Música]
me convenció me disfracé de mendigo para
huir y volví a dissadeva así fue como
tuve la idea de irme para Europa
[Música]
es un portal mediante el cual ustedes
reciben historias sobrecogedoras
es un portal sobre los migrantes y para
ellos muchos nos cuentan sus historias
para arrojar luz sobre las migraciones
eso fue lo que llevó a muhammad a
compartir su historia con nosotros nos
dijo que miles de migrantes están
sometidos a la tortura y al abuso en
Libia y que hay que ayudarlos pero esta
historia no tiene imágenes ni videos
como va a contarla
dibujo la información usando una técnica
de animación llamada news sketchen
algunas historias son imposibles de
contar por razones de seguridad porque
la vida de las personas o la de sus
familias está en juego la difusión de
esas historias con sonido e Imagen
pueden tener consecuencias Por otra
parte las personas que esas historias
dibujadas no sufren porque están
protegidas por el dibujo que funciona
como un filtro que preserva a los
usuarios del dolor que puede provocar
las historias así
todo esto obedece a un rigor
periodístico
en julio de 2017 salía Etiopía con un
grupo de hombres jóvenes y de
traficantes el 16 de Julio entramos a
Sudán por garabat
en ondurman tomamos nuestra última
comida en territorio sudanés a partir de
ahí Los Traficantes quisieron
debilitarnos para podernos controlar en
el camino que llevaba hacia Libia el
hambre y la tortura empezaron en Sudán y
llegamos hasta el desierto nos quedamos
ahí seis días en Sudán nos encontramos
con un puesto de control militar
Los Traficantes pagaron
entramos a Libia el 28 de julio de 2017
nos metieron en un camión cubrían el
techo cuando estábamos en las ciudades y
lo destapaban en el desierto
[Música]
Es difícil llegar hasta Europa tenía que
cruzar somalia Etiopía Sudán y llegar
hasta Libia allí la inestabilidad
política y la inseguridad han favorecido
el surgimiento de grupos criminales que
explotan a los migrantes estábamos en la
región de alcofrar cerca al pueblo de
taxirbú
llegamos a un lugar que parecía un
almacén
había una casa rodeada de un patio donde
estaban estacionados unos vehículos y
guardias armados
había un portón con un candado grande y
también varios locales que ellos
utilizaban para el contrabando de
cigarrillos drogas y alcohol nos dejaron
en un sótano
[Música]
al cabo de siete meses ya éramos 79
migrantes nos trataban con mucha
brutalidad acoso insultos tortura
violación asesinato
[Música]
[Aplausos]
nunca me olvidaré de los que estaban ahí
conmigo algunos de ellos me ayudaron no
sabíamos cuánto tiempo íbamos a
quedarnos en ese lugar no teníamos
ningún contacto con el mundo exterior
Los Traficantes tenían los teléfonos
móviles la mayor parte del tiempo solo
nos permitían hacer llamadas limitadas
para conseguirles dinero
[Música]
Y
cómo hacen esos contrabandistas para
sacarle dinero a los migrantes
lo hacen de distintas maneras
graban a los migrantes mientras los
torturan o a veces cuando los violan
después envían las imágenes a las
familias y exigen dinero por la
liberación de sus hijos
solo recibíamos una comida al día pasta
y agua 25 personas murieron de
tuberculosis y por la violencia de Los
Traficantes
entraban para darnos de comer y nos
golpeaban pedían a las mujeres que
subieran y les ordenaban desnudarse una
vez trate de impedirles que golpearan a
una mujer embarazada de todas maneras la
golpearon perdió a su bebé
[Música]
nuestra humanidad se desmoronaba nadie
sabía lo que estaba pasando en nuestro
mundo tan extraño cada uno de nosotros
tenía su historia y sus motivaciones en
la vida
[Música]
amina era más fuerte que todo eso
emanaba una energía Maravillosa en ese
lugar miserable portaba esperanza y todo
el mundo trataba de descubrir cuál era
su secreto rezaba y ayunaba tenía
compasión por los demás por su devoción
Los Traficantes no se atrevían a
acercarse a ella eso mal y como yo viene
de mogadicio en la vida solo le queda a
su madre
la vi el primer mes cuando llegué al
almacén poco a poco aprendimos a
conocernos y hablarnos tiene cuatro años
menos que yo ella era diferente su
presencia me tranquilizaba me habló de
sus sueños y de lo que quería hacer
después de esa pesadilla
estaba segura de que saldría de ahí me
atrajo a su mundo y yo creía en todo lo
que me decía
[Música]
y después Un día le dije lo que yo
quería
quiero estar contigo por el resto de mi
vida
[Música]
en medio del desierto libio dentro de un
almacén subterráneo entre más de 80
esclavizados que parecían muertos
vivientes
torturados le pedí que se casara conmigo
Ella aceptó
[Música]
[Aplausos]
nuestros sueños se convirtió en asunto
de todos nos rodeaban como si
representáramos su propia Esperanza
teníamos que legitimar nuestra Unión yo
quería hablar con su madre en somalia
unos amigos nos ayudaron y conseguimos
un teléfono
[Música]
Después de varios intentos logramos
contactar a su madre que inmediatamente
bendijo nuestra relación pero faltaba
dar otro paso importante
necesitábamos un aval religioso en
nuestro mundo subterráneo había un
hombre devoto que conocía la religión
aceptó casarnos actuando como imán sin
duda fue el primer matrimonio de ese
estilo en un lugar así nos comprometimos
a vivir juntos animados por la esperanza
de salir de esa cárcel
[Música]
dos meses después de nuestra boda está
yo Una disputa entre los traficantes
entendimos que algunos de nosotros
serían llevados a otra parte
[Música]
vinieron otros traficantes Y decidieron
llevarnos a la fuerza nos hicieron salir
y nos separaron en dos grupos
[Música]
traté de hablar con ellos pero me
golpearon con un objeto de hierro
fue incapaz de moverme Mientras los veía
llevarse uno de los grupos en dos
vehículos
[Música]
mi mujer estaba con ellos quedé
inconsciente
el primer vehículo se volcó saliendo del
lugar
el segundo en el que estaba mi mujer
llegó a Benny ulite en el norte
[Música]
ella estuvo ahí unos meses hasta que
decidieron llevarla a la costa le
pidieron 10 mil dólares ella Sólo pagó
2000 pero a veces también llevaban a
personas que no habían pagado el total
que les habían pedido
[Música]
en la ruta que llevaba hacia la costa el
conductor perdió el control
[Aplausos]
hubo dos muertos
ella sobrevivió junto con otros 25
migrantes
fueron llevados a un hospital en Benny
ulite
un periodista libio quiso saber más
sobre las circunstancias del accidente
pero los hombres armados se lo
impidieron
[Música]
muham supo todos estos detalles mucho
tiempo después
verán que le pasó a mina y cómo se
enteró muham de su historia
Los Traficantes no respetan el
matrimonio ni la dignidad humana Los
Traficantes ignoran el derecho o la
dignidad
o respetan el amor ni el matrimonio ni
cualquier otra relación humana verán que
el secuestro de estos migrantes también
lleva a la explotación de sus cuerpos
los migrantes que no murieron fueron
llevados a una habitación
la puerta estaba cerrada con llave y era
vigilada
amina estaba con otras siete personas en
ese hospital inquietante y extraño
[Música]
algunos hombres vestían uniforme de
seguridad y llevaban ahí a los migrantes
para encerrarlos y revenderlos llevaron
a mina a una habitación donde se quedó
sola entró en pánico porque parecía una
sala de operaciones sintió que en ese
hospital pasaba algo anormal abrió la
puerta y huyó fue Entonces cuando vio al
periodista libio al que anteriormente
los hombres armados la habían impedido
ver a los migrantes él había insistido
en quedarse en el hospital porque una
niña cuya madre había muerto en el
accidente le dijo que ahí pasaba algo
raro
a mina habló con él en el baño porque
esa era la única manera
le dijo que algunos migrantes
desaparecían y que la situación era
aterradora el periodista creyó y
contactó a las fuerzas de seguridad que
trabajaban con las Naciones Unidas de
inmediato llegaron nuevos hombres
armados Pero los que estaban antes
habían desaparecido encontraron una niña
a la que le habían sacado un riñón lo
que justificó después los temores de
amina
cada segundo que pasa aumenta La amenaza
de muerte que pesa sobre amina
la pérdida de amina era la principal
motivación de muham Y eso lo llevó a
tomar la decisión de rechazar la
servitud y los abusos cometidos por los
traficantes fue una decisión
Irreversible sentía que entre más pasaba
el tiempo mayor era el peligro que
acechaba a mina tenía que actuar
durante ese tiempo a nosotros Nos
llevaron a otro lugar era una granja
cerca de taxirbú había una casa para los
traficantes y un almacén grande para
nosotros el almacén Estaba rodeado por
un muro los autos entraban al patio por
un portón
[Música]
el comportamiento de Los Traficantes era
un más cruel torturaban a las personas
con electricidad
[Música]
se llevaban a las mujeres por la fuerza
durante la noche y las volvían a traer
por la mañana una de ellas murió unas
horas después de su regreso entre
nosotros
[Música]
estuve ahí varios meses y traté de
obtener información sobre mi mujer
seguía viva podía salir para encontrarla
empecé a pensar en un plan de escape
[Música]
hablé con otros migrantes algunos de
ellos tenían mucho miedo
me designaron como el líder por mis
tomas de posición y por mi edad siempre
trataba defender a las niñas a las que
acosaban y torturaban me respetaban el
plan de escape era bastante sencillo
como podrían ver Pensé en todos los
detalles como por ejemplo quería hacerlo
contamos la cantidad de traficantes que
venían a vernos habitualmente siempre
eran entre 3 y 7 y vamos a cruzar el
punto de no retorno
decidimos poner en marcha nuestro plan
el viernes 26 de enero de 2018 porque
ese día habría muchos habitantes en la
mezquita para el resto colectivo esa era
nuestra mejor protección contra los
hombres armados les dije que los fieles
nos iban a ayudar le temíamos sobre todo
a los hombres que llevaban uniformes de
la policía o del ejército porque
trabajaban con Los Traficantes sé que
eran Cómplices el supervisor del almacén
donde nosotros estábamos vestía un
uniforme esperamos el momento de la
comida para actuar incluso Aunque fueran
más de tres incluso Aunque estuvieran
armados nosotros éramos muchos más
[Música]
jamás es joven es estudiante de
informática no tiene ninguna experiencia
en combate o en confrontación a pesar de
su corta edad muhammad elaboró y ejecutó
un plan contra los traficantes para él y
los demás
era un estudiante un civil Pacífico pero
su plan lo convirtió en el líder del
grupo
utilizó el efecto sorpresa contra los
traficantes se puso de acuerdo con los
demás y todos lo siguieron
[Música]
simule que les iba a hablar seguido por
otros 10 amigos
los atamos
[Música]
también había otros afuera trataron de
detenernos los golpeamos también los
atamos y salimos por el portón grande
éramos más de 90
[Música]
caminamos por el desierto más o menos
durante una hora
[Música]
los más fuertes entre nosotros llevaban
a los más débiles
[Música]
había una docena de enfermos dos de
ellos murieron
llegamos a tasibo
las personas de la mezquita se quedaron
muy sorprendidas cuando nos vieron
parecíamos muertos vivientes
nos hicieron muchas preguntas nos
tomaron fotos llegó la policía
nos quedamos ahí cuatro días después nos
llevaron a la ciudad de alcofrá que
tiene un aeropuerto con ayuda del
alcalde y algunas personas estuvimos en
un refugio durante unos dos meses la
policía nos trató con respeto
el director del Refugio nos apoyó y nos
envió bajo protección militar a trípoli
donde está el alto comisionado de las
Naciones Unidas para los refugiados
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en este punto de la historia muhammad
aún no sabe nada de amina
ninguno de los dos sabía que había
pasado con el otro a pesar de eso a mina
nunca perdió la esperanza
se negó a irse de Libia sin su marido
cuando llegó al centro de las Naciones
Unidas con todo lo que le había pasado y
dijo que no se iría sin él sabía que
estaba vivo y lo esperaría
[Música]
llegué a un edificio y me puse en una
fila de espera
[Música]
mi mujer estaba ahí
me vio corrió hacia mí
un soldado la detuvo
[Música]
ella le dijo que quería ver a su amor a
su esposo ellos no le creyeron
[Música]
empezó a gritar mi nombre yo le rogué a
un soldado que me dejara verla
Finalmente nos creyeron
ambos pensábamos que el otro había
muerto nuestra alegría fue
indescriptible
[Música]
cuando muham llegó al centro de las
Naciones Unidas se sorprendió al ver que
sabían casi todo sobre él
a mí no les había contado toda la
historia Aunque tenían tan solo 20 años
actúa con inteligencia instintiva no lo
pensó demasiado intervino con lucidez
para proteger su vida y la de muhammata
en noviembre de 2018 Nos llevaron a
níger donde había una misión de la
oficina francesa de protección a los
refugiados y a patrias
[Música]
a pesar de su corta edad
muhammad yamira parece el mayor es por
lo que vivieron desde que se fueron de
su país hasta que llegaron a Libia y por
todo lo que ocurrió después hoy en día
su historia en común continua
[Música]
después de ver este documental damos
pase a la discusión sobre el tema
central y comienzo dando un tema como
punto de inicio del debate Europa
registró en el 2022 unos 330.000 cruces
ilegales a su territorio se trata del
mayor número de entradas irregulares
desde el año 2016 casi la mitad tuvieron
lugar a través de la llamada ruta de los
balcanes occidentales que va desde
Grecia hasta Europa central a través de
países como macedonia del Norte Albania
kosovo Montenegro Bosnia herzegovina y
Serbia pues para analizar este tema
hemos invitado a Beatriz Escobar
Cristian y ella es estudios de Asia y
África también es profesora de la
facultad de ciencias políticas de la
UNAM y también está con nosotros Silvia
peratso ella es magister en historia con
especialización en África contemporánea
a las dos les doy la bienvenida al
programa Gracias por estar con nosotros
y comienzo con Beatriz preguntándole
Beatriz qué balance puede hacer usted de
las estrategias que han instaurado a lo
largo de los últimos años para combatir
justamente la migración irregular han
fallado o son exitosas
pues desde luego es difícil hacer un
balance pero en general podemos observar
que lejos de que hayan disminuido los
flujos migratorios en los últimos años
han ido en aumento porque desde luego
obedecen a causas profundas que muchas
veces no se tienen en cuenta en las
distintas políticas que se diseñan por
lo tanto es difícil atacar el tema de
las migraciones si no se Atacan al mismo
tiempo las causas más profundas que las
generan y el caso de somalia sería
paradigmático es difícil pensar que
dejará de haber migraciones de somalíes
hacia otras partes del mundo cuando en
realidad pues somalia sabemos que es un
escenario de conflictos de diverso tipo
desde hace ya varias décadas y entonces
en tanto no se resuelva esta situación
pues es muy difícil realmente que se
puedan
cortar de pronto los productos
migratorios independientemente de los
diferentes tipos de políticas que se
diseñen para ello Sí y Silvia Cuál es su
opinión primero la de la bienvenida al
programa y cuál es su opinión sobre
estas políticas instauradas han fallado
están siendo exitosas o simplemente
están tomando un poco más de tiempo para
empezar a dar los resultados que están
esperando los gobiernos que las han
instaurado
Bueno en realidad yo comparto la
división de Beatriz porque en realidad
no se trata si las políticas de los
estados receptores son buenas o no el
problema es que los flujos migratorios
van en aumento porque las causas
profundas que motivan la migración
siguen activas en el continente africano
acá había tres nombró precisamente la
crisis somalí yo le agregaría lo el otro
tema que se muestra en el en el
documental que acabamos de ver que es la
cuestión de Libia Y tenemos ahí dos
problemas muy muy importantes que es la
crisis del Estado no la desintegración
de dos estados uno que virtualmente no
existe desde hace 30 años y otro que
lleva diez años de crisis no entonces
mientras eso no se solucione las
políticas migratorias que se puedan
tomar del otro lado del Mediterráneo van
a resultar siempre ineficaces porque los
flujos migratorios van a seguir
existiendo no De todas maneras vale la
pena también aclarar que la cuestión del
Mediterráneo el paso por el Mediterráneo
no es el único paso que usan aquellos
afectados tanto por la crisis Libia como
por la crisis somalí y tal también como
hemos visto en el en el documental uno
de los pasos más usados nuestra tarde ir
a Europa sino cruzar el golfo de adén y
llegar a al Medio Oriente digamos a
yemen donde las situaciones parecida a
la que hemos visto en el documental
Silvia continuó con usted para hacer la
ronda de la inversa y quiero que
profundicemos justamente en el escenario
que están presentando estos países
particularmente somalia un país del
cuerno de África con muchísimos
problemas internos y con una ausencia
del estado y capaz e incapacidad del
Estado para hacer presencia en las
diferentes regiones de ese país otro
escenario muy distinto nos presenta
Libia que se quedó con un proceso de
revolución en marcha como en una pausa
constante que no ha llegado a su punto
final profundicemos entre las dos quiero
que ustedes armen el escenario de lo que
se está viviendo en esos países comienzo
con Silvia
Bueno muy bien en realidad lleva
una Lleva más de 30 años no por ahí su
su punto de inicio podría ser el 1991
pero podrá ir también podríamos ir a
finales de la década del 70 a partir de
ese momento el estado somalí implosionó
en un principio porque los clanes que es
la unidad digamos este primaria de la
sociedad somalí esos clanes se armaron y
y pelearon entre sí por la búsqueda del
poder desde ese momento en adelante la
crisis sigue hasta hoy virtualmente hoy
en día tenemos tres regiones en digamos
distintas esas somalia está dividido en
tres regiones diferentes que obedecen a
a factores de poder distintos y a
instituciones de poder diferentes una de
ellas es somaliante es virtualmente
independiente otras puntland que
semiautónoma y el resto que es del
centro y el sur del país que es a donde
se refiere el documental que hemos visto
antes
en esa zona hay una parte que está
tomada por milicias islámicas que en
este momento son las milicias al shabat
y que son las que persiguen mucha gente
muchas veces a gente que quiere escapar
porque los necesitan dentro del
territorio precisamente para pelear y el
resto del del territorio que está en
manos de un gobierno muy débil que no
puede extender Su autoridad por sobre
todo el territorio sí Beatriz que
podemos decir del caso libio que más
allá del contexto político de esta como
mencionaba yo está Revolución que no ha
terminado que nunca tuvo un punto final
es el punto de partida del territorio
africano para saltar directamente al
territorio de la Unión Europea la
mayoría de las personas que intentan
cruzar lo hacen hacia la isla italiana
de la pedusa O a Malta o al sur de
Italia
sí efectivamente no podemos separar el
contexto político interno de Libia de el
hecho de que se haya convertido en uno
de los
pasos por excelencia por donde mucha
población de origen africano intenta
cruzar hacia Europa y en este caso pues
es muy importante
considerar como a partir del
derrocamiento y del asesinato de galafi
Pues el territorio se divide
un poco al estilo de somalia Aunque si
viendo diferentes lógicas pero el
territorio queda dividido en tres
diversos grupos que van ejerciendo el
control en alguna parte o en otra pero
no se puede establecer no se ha podido
establecer hasta el momento Un gobierno
fuerte que tenga el control de todo el
territorio y por esta situación es
digamos más fácil para todos estos
grupos dedicados al tráfico de personas
tratar de ir pasando por los distintos
territorios donde pueden establecer
contacto o establecer alianzas con
distintos grupos no esto desde luego
Sería mucho más difícil de realizarse
y hubiera Un gobierno nacional
centralizado fuerte que
en cierta manera de cierta manera
impidiera este
esta difusión del poder entre distintas
regiones Beatriz continuó con usted para
que toquemos el tema central de este
documental y es el tráfico de personas
los protagonistas de esta historia
fueron justamente Víctimas de este de
esta problemática es lo que se narra
allí en la historia que tanto ha hecho
la comunidad internacional para
evidenciar y dar a conocer esta práctica
que tiene lugar no solamente en África
también en otros sectores de Asia y
también de el mismo continente americano
a través del tapón del Darién incluso
hasta la frontera entre México y Estados
Unidos pero la realidad africana es un
poco más compleja precisamente por lo
que usted dice Beatriz porque aquí en
cierta forma esas ausencias de estado
permiten una complicidad de las
autoridades en este negocio millonario
del tráfico de personas hacia Europa por
qué no hay una mayor difusión de esta
problemática
desafortunadamente algo que podemos
observar es lo que sucede en muchos
otros casos con muchos otros temas que
afectan a esta región es
un gran desinterés y una gran
desinformación por la región porque se
le considera como una zona que de cierta
manera Está alejada digamos de los
problemas internacionales y entonces van
apareciendo distintos distintas
situaciones de conflicto
a las que no se les presta la debilidad
atención en su momento y que van
justamente generando toda esta serie de
movimientos de personas no también
diversas situaciones económicas sabemos
que algunos países africanos
enfrentan situaciones económicas
difíciles y por lo tanto también esto
genera muchas migraciones pero digamos
que no se atienden los problemas de
origen y esto ha permitido o ha
facilitado el constante flujo de
personas a través de distintas rutas en
el caso de Libia como lo señalaba hace
un momento pues es
paradigmático porque es un lugar donde
han estallado diversas situaciones
que facilitan que hacen más
Expedito poder llevar a las personas a
través de estas rutas pero los problemas
no se originan solamente en línea sino
que atienden al resto del continente y
Silvia Cuál es su opinión sobre este
tema sobre esta falta de visibilidad de
esta problemática
Bueno tal como decía Beatriz muchas
veces es una problemática la que no se
le presta la divina la debida
importancia no en ambos escenarios de
una u otra forma está presente en
Naciones Unidas está presente la unión
africana sobre todo en el caso somalí
sin embargo no hay políticas activas
respecto a digamos que permitan evitar
este tipo de este de tráfico no tal como
hemos podido ver en el en el documental
las personas que que por ahí buscan un
futuro mejor en medio oriente o buscan
un futuro mejor cruzando del
Mediterráneo digamos son Víctimas de
estos traficantes y ahí sufren torturas
abusos tráfico de órganos que es otra
cosa que también podemos dislumbrar
Dentro de este documental y son
problemáticas que más allá de tener
varias resoluciones del Consejo de
Seguridad no hay una
estados africanos sino en realidad de la
comunidad
Bueno pues vamos a retomar ahora la
conexión con Silvia para para entender
su punto de vista sobre esta falta de
visibilidad internacional
de esta problemática en paso a
preguntarle ahora a Beatriz sobre las
estrategias que utiliza por ejemplo el
continente europeo para hacer frente a
este a esta problemática una de las
medidas que han tomado es exteriorizar
estas fronteras de la Unión Europea es
decir pasarle el tema del control
fronterizo a otro país que sea Barrera
para evitar que la gente llegue al
territorio de la Unión Europea un caso
es por ejemplo Marruecos evitando que
entre gente a España o de Turquía hacia
Grecia solo por mencionar algunos
también está por ejemplo el caso de
Serbia y de Bosnia herzegovina hacia
países como Croacia Austria o Hungría Y
qué se puede decir de estas medidas
Beatriz de simplemente tratar de mover
un poco más la frontera en en cuanto al
término geográfico pero no hay
soluciones en los países desde donde se
está originando la migración
efectivamente lo que vemos es justo esto
no
solucionar un problema fino desde mi
punto de vista lo que se hace es
justamente lo que usted está señalando
transferirlo o tratar de transferirlo a
otras regiones donde no nos afecte pero
pues en un tema instancia el tema de la
migración termina por afectar Pues
básicamente a todo el mundo porque es
algo que influye constantemente En
diversas dinámicas no Entonces
se ha aprobado a lo largo de la historia
que tratar de cerrar las fronteras
Resulta ser poco efectivo a menos de que
se implementen políticas bastante
pretorianas pero en general los intentos
por cerrar las fronteras a nivel
internacional esto Generalmente poco
efectivas precisamente porque los
humanos tenemos esta tendencia Pues a
tratar de buscar nuestra sobrevivencia
donde quiera que está claro
y esto lo en un en un problema
importante
un caso extremo digamos sería por
ejemplo el caso de
Reino Unido con Ruanda que ya tiene la
propuesta de regresar a los migrantes
hacia Ruanda en los que traten de llegar
a Reino Unido como una opción para
tratar de solucionar el problema Pero
nuevamente no es una solución sino
tratar de desplazarlo Claro ya vamos
llegando al bloque final de este
análisis de esta situación migratoria
desde África Asia el continente europeo
vamos entonces analizar Beatriz allí en
México los puntos claves de esta de esta
problemática que puede seguir entonces
para la Unión Europea con estas altas
cifras de personas que están llegando a
su territorio de manera irregular va a
ampliar entonces estas terceras
fronteras va a endurecer sus políticas
migratorias porque también hay que
decirlo los países europeos necesitan
mano migrante qué pueden hacer ahí
efectivamente los países europeos ya
desde hace varios años han requerido
justamente de la integración de fuerza
de trabajo proveniente de otros países
y desde mi punto de vista es un poco una
política de doble moral digamos
Por una parte censurar la migración pero
al mismo tiempo aprovechar sus ventajas
Qué se puede hacer pues ha habido muchas
iniciativas por parte de diversas
organizaciones incluso de la sociedad
civil europea que han tratado de
responder a las necesidades que plantea
la migración Tratando de buscar una
mejor forma de integrar a los grupos que
llegan que es una buena parte de lo que
se requiere porque efectivamente la
llegada de estas grandes cantidades de
personas a los países europeos supone
retos desde el punto de vista económico
pero también desde el punto de vista de
la integración
social digamos entonces es algo que se
tiene que atender y ha habido muchas
diversas iniciativas por parte de los de
los propios europeos claro Sería
cuestión de que los gobiernos traten de
sistematizar un poco más de integrar
estas diferentes iniciativas y Silvia su
opinión sobre Qué puede hacer la Unión
Europea para hacer frente a esta
creciente llegada de personas que llegan
al territorio europeo de manera ilegal y
regular
Bueno en realidad lo primero sería
digamos tener una política migratoria
que no tenga que ver con el rechazo y la
expulsión no
sino que en realidad habría que
diagramar una estrategia concertada de
todos los estados de la Unión Europea
buscando una cooperación económica y
social entre ellos de manera de poder
digamos elaborar una red de contención y
con eso Después hablar
digamos una vez que lo que digamos que
se los haya recibido y que se los haya
digamos colocado en un lugar seguro
hablar con sus estados de origen para
ver qué estrategias en conjunto Y a
partir de la cooperación internacional
se pueden establecer para para la
seguridad de todos digamos no
sostengo también lo de la doble moral
que escuchaba antes a Beatriz decir que
es verdad que por un lado le sirve como
fuerza de trabajo y mano de obra barata
y por otro lado sufren todo tipo de
discriminación en tanto no solo para
establecerse sino también por cuestión
de documentación y es eso lo que la
comunidad internacional necesita
encargarse no el diálogo a partir de la
cooperación y las instituciones
internacionales Unión Europea la unión
africana este Naciones Unidas pueden
elaborar para esos protocolos conjuntos
que permitan no la expulsión no que
terminen después siendo a partir sino
que puedan encontrar un lugar no donde
donde establecerse Y dónde poder seguir
su vida en paz sobre todo de origen no
se lo puede garantizar Silvia y muy
puntual y que hacer con los países que
son origen de la migración caso somalia
Libia Nigeria los países del África
subsahariana que tienen tanta
inestabilidad política
Bueno eso es el punto clave de todo lo
que hemos tenido
en esta charla No si esos estados son
incapaces de asegurar la seguridad de su
población porque están en proceso de
desintegración ahí tienen que estar los
organismos internacionales para
ayudarlos no Y para no para no ahondar y
no profundizar en la en la división por
ejemplo lo que hemos visto en Libia de
la comunidad internacional apoyando a
las distintas partes no unos a los a los
islamistas y otros a los militares por
ejemplo Rusia a un lado Turquía del otro
Eso no ayuda no colabora Entonces eso
sigue digamos provocando que que se
ahonden las causas de la migración y en
el caso somalí las Naciones Unidas con
la unión africana necesitan una firme
política Para apoyar a las autoridades
legales y de A poco ahí digamos ir
solucionando una situación que es mucho
más dramática porque no es únicamente el
el tema de la desintegración también
está la cuestión de la sequía de la
pobreza extrema no de la falta general
de recursos que eso sale a partir de la
juve de la colaboración de la sociedad
internacional Pues a Silvia y a Beatriz
les agradezco mucho por haber estado con
nosotros hoy en el reporteros el
documental gracias a ustedes también por
la sintonía Pueden seguir en compañía de
France 24 sigan con nuestra programación
[Música]